[Music]
alright time once again for the matinee
shows that in matinee 82 I believe now
the first movie that we saw this week
this was a good one you guys um although
I can kind of see why maybe some people
might not like it but I legitimately
love for this movie this is the varium
oh yeah yes indeed we are that [ __ ] last
night I woke up thinking about it that's
definitely what it was okay now this
this movie here all right
it's a science fiction horror movie
think of it almost kind of like a
Twilight Zone yeah black mirror yeah I'd
like to tell you everything about it but
you can't spoil this one because it's
better to go into this [ __ ] not really
know what the [ __ ] going on all right
yeah and I saw just a few minutes of the
trailer on Xbox man oh yeah I got to see
this the best part about this it has
this the same leading cast as in [ __ ]
art itself too far to self defense the
Eisenberg and imogen yeah yeah I thought
I thought you said poops like Pookie
thanks a week I'll call her pokes okay
and this movie here man was [ __ ]
badass it's weird
yeah if you look at the trailer you'll
see some people they go to like a real
estate agent somewhere in England and
they take them to this housing complex
and all the houses look exactly the
[ __ ] like exactly alike real generic
green looking green houses weren't there
greener they were green of green houses
just real artificial and the guy who's
taking them there is just kind of like
he reminds me of the character David
from Prometheus and alien covenant he
Scott it seems like a robot or something
yeah he's like really off-putting and
they get there and that's when this
[ __ ] weird event happens and you're
like is this like an paranormal what is
this and man I don't want to blow it
just [ __ ] see it it's just a [ __ ]
this was like kind of hard to talk about
without spoiling it because okay now
this came out I think this premiered at
the Cannes Film Festival last May like
in May of 2019 and it's I
an Irish director I believe but the
funding for it is like Irish / Danish /
Belgian I think yeah so they're not on
any of the Hollywood game they're doing
their own [ __ ] thing and this movies
really unique I like it yeah this is
like a very European you know it's a
European funded movie but without being
boring it was some European ships
[ __ ] boring well some American ships
I'm Mary Osborne but but yeah so the
thing about I remember seeing it's
really weird because I remember seeing a
trailer for this in the theater like a
long time ago like sometimes last summer
or something like that and going man
that looks pretty cool and like pretty
weird and then I kind of forgot about it
but then just lately I guess it got
released in Ireland and then they put it
up on VOD because we rented it on Xbox
and I was like oh yeah remember like
seeing the trailer for that and like you
know I saw some other channels like
reviewing it $6.99 for the rental but go
ahead and do it man it's worth every
penny of it it's a weird-ass [ __ ]
movie yeah I mean just was like riveted
those movie that never happens it's not
boring at all I'm just like what the
[ __ ] is going on and it just takes you
through the whole damn thing now you got
to pay attention in the beginning
because in the beginning you don't
realize it but the beginning is setting
it up yeah it's pretty much telling you
like what what this movie's gonna be
about about about nature and nature and
all that good and there's things in
nature that are any good endings and
there's my [ __ ] happening in mysterious
rounds yeah and [ __ ] and like cycles
life cycles yeah life cycles and
reproduction is [ __ ] like that we're
being so like cryptic you gotta be but
like I said it's really really hard it's
really really hard to talk about this
about spoiling it you know what it's
like I was watching like a couple other
reviews of this and somebody in one of
the comments on one of the other reviews
said that this movie was like and I
thought this was very accurate
they said this is like Pleasantville
meets Dark City and I was like oh yeah I
don't like that but it's like it's
really like very Twilight Zone a very
black mirror reminded
a little bit of cynic dosha New York
although that was a little bit more
comedic give me it's a little bit of a
David Lynch vibe - yeah um yeah cuz the
and I would say that it's also kind of
like a something like this could happen
in a Star Trek episode except it's dark
very dark some of some Star Trek
episodes from the next generation that
first season of the next generation like
the black goo that hate the person and
this and that some of them have bad
endings and this is kind of like that
yeah but which you know I guess it kind
of spoiled it saying it has a bad end if
not really by the time by the time the
end starts to come you know what it is
that you're dealing with yeah because
then you remember back to the to the
very beginning of the movie of what when
they tried to set it up and there's a
bunch afterwards if you're kind of
confused about what happened you could
there's some guys that made some videos
explaining it and it was like I thought
some guys have different theories on it
but I'm gonna go with the obvious theory
which is set up in the very beginning
about what it is yeah it reminded me
know it was it's kind of happening in
the same kind of mental space as that
movie with the damn table that went up
and down through the damn prison tears
oh yeah yeah the platform kind of like a
oh it's kind of like in the same genre
as platform but science fiction or
somebody um somebody else compared it to
a movie called triangle remember that
one it was like a cruise ship like they
found the cruise ship and then they were
just kept like living in the same loop
and Shelia that's um it's not really
like that but it's like a similar kind
of mind bender yeah type of [ __ ] you
know what I mean for one reason or
another I'm not you know damn I don't
want to dance spoil it it's best you
know I mean like weak some of the
analysis are out there I don't want to
give an analysis because they're already
out there and some people have done good
jobs on them yeah make your own make
your own conclusion on what this is
about
I'm pretty sure it's it's a natural
phenomenon and probably some kind of
extraterrestrial extraterrestrial
but yeah it's like I do feel like I did
see some people that had commented like
I said on various YouTube videos that
were like you know that liked the movie
but they were like what the [ __ ] that I
just watched but to me it seemed like if
you paid attention to the very beginning
you would know then you would know like
what they were getting at
yeah and this five man is crucial it is
and and I like to that it's like I mean
I have to say that like the two leads in
this you know Jesse Eisenberg and Imogen
Poots who were playing Tom and Gemma
like a boyfriend a girlfriend and that
both their performances were amazing I
mean because pretty much the almost the
whole entire movie centers around them
there's not really that many other
people in the cast or anything like
there's just a couple other people but
just the way that they like interact
with one another and you know other
people that come into the thing later on
was just like really amazing and I mean
this is like like I see a lot of movies
that I really like and [ __ ] but this one
I mean I was just like sitting there
like on the edge of my seat the whole
time and like when not when it was over
I was like I legitimately loved this
movie yeah I was riveted to it of course
because you know I mean it's not a super
dialogue heavy movie it's a survival
situation it's like survival horror but
it's science fiction these people get
into this damn situation and they're
trying to figure out how the [ __ ]
they're gonna get out of this yeah
they're not even sure what it is well
yeah as you wouldn't yeah cuz when you
when you when you start watching the
movie like what the [ __ ] is going on
here well they're like the same way yeah
and they're doing like exactly do a
chunk normal person right you right like
they didn't really make any dumb
decisions or anything and it was just
kind of like they were acting the way a
normal person well yeah the only
criticisms I heard about this much
intelligence criticism so I mean you
gonna have some dumbasses like [ __ ] that
movie oh you didn't make any sense well
it makes a lot of sense it's not you
weren't [ __ ] paying attention to the
[ __ ] and you weren't trying to think
your way out of it
some kind of criticism that I can kind
understand some people said well you
know it's kind of like a stretched-out
Twilight Zone yeah I heard that and I'm
like what's wrong with that yeah most
Twilight's yeah it's not a bad thing
episodes are standing to the
today the test of time a lot of those
stories yeah we're well [ __ ] written
I mean you know a 16 year old today can
go on you can go on Netflix and watch
all those old yeah they're all they're
watching and be like minutes [ __ ]
trippy [ __ ] cuz some of them were good
and some of them didn't age too well but
they would didn't age that well back
then right there were but there are some
classic Twilight Zone episodes that just
can't be topped and they've inspired a
lot of the [ __ ] sci-fi or that you
see it today well yeah like a lot of the
writers in trauma like Richard Matheson
and Harlan Ellison and stuff like that
it's like a lot of the concepts that
they kind of wrote about like are still
kind of coming to fruition like I said
in Black Mirror and stuff as well but
yeah it's like to me saying oh it's like
a stretched-out Twilight Zone episode
that's not a criticism right because
honestly some of the best Twilight Zone
episodes I would have watched a
feature-length movie about that concept
yeah the closer this is like that
closest in Twilight Zone this one
reminds me of the one we remember the
girls voice was coming out of nowhere
the little girl yeah yeah and she's
somehow in the middle of night rolled
out of bed and somehow went to a
parallel dimension like in the wall he
calls over his physicist buddy to try to
find where the girl is yeah this one's a
little bit like that and I don't like a
situation like that you don't know
what's real yeah
you don't know what's real but you find
out that it's very real what you're
seeing but this is definitely this is
definitely one it works on that level
like the sci-fi level but it also works
on a metaphorical level that's right
there's two different focus difference
like 200 lessons is teaching yeah and so
I really really liked the way they did
that and the way that they set that up
like I said I can't really like it's
pissing me off because I really want to
kind of spoil it I was watching like
Austin Burke who reviewed this movie
also and he said kind of said the same
thing he's like I'm gonna really try not
to spoil it because it's really really
hard to talk about if you can't it's a
survival horror sci-fi story that also
teaches a lesson about life yeah okay
it's taken life and condensing it into a
few months in this story
yeah and it's none and it's this showing
the natural elements of life but
in a [ __ ] situation to where if you
see it happens so quickly it looks awful
[ __ ] unnatural yeah you know it looks
very brutal yeah if you see life
condensed down just into a few months
yeah into like less than a year yeah so
it just it's really like so I feel like
if you're into like weird creepy like
slightly surreal kind of sci-fi horror
thriller type of thing yeah like I said
if you're really if you like black
mirror or Twilight Zone if you like
David Lynch or you know anything that's
like that then you will probably really
dig this yeah it's funny there's also a
little bit of humor in the beginning
because they come in contact with this
phenomenon and it is kind of funny at
first but they don't realize the like
repercussions yeah of what of what this
means it's just this is a classic movie
it stands on its own it's just to me
this stands up there with the art of
self-defense yeah even though it's very
very different
yeah but it's a different tone but but
these these two actors here man [ __ ]
I got a lot of respect for them they did
a great job in both movies and it seems
like seems like they're working with
movies that have substance to them yeah
they're cracking interesting of picking
interesting stories yeah which but yeah
this is this is definitely one you know
one of the best ones that I've seen like
the last few years yeah easily like as
soon as it was over I was like like man
let me get this one and the other one on
blu-ray and it's definitely one that I
would want to watch again and like
discuss with other people and say this
is one of those ones that you need to
like discuss all there were little
details about a book a book appears in
it and in the book there's a bunch of
damn drawings in there that want to go
back and look at it again yeah because
the there was you know what's happening
but a lot of little details weren't
explained but it the movie tried to give
you hints yeah about what was happening
and like I said there's more than one
interpretation although I think that the
interpretation that we came up and most
of the other reviewers I feel like kind
of got the same thing next more so it
does make more sense to me although
there is another alternative work to but
I feel like there's more evidence wrong
for
thing it's a life form that they came
across that's all you know yeah I
believe but yeah this is like a really
really cool movie so it's you know it's
I'm sure it's on Amazon Prime and [ __ ]
like that too but we just run it on Xbox
and it's excellent excellent film and I
would definitely recommend it if you're
into like weird function it's a must-see
mind-bending sci-fi it's a must like
it's it was really really yeah
hey y'all so second movie that I watched
this week was actually not an xbox
rental it was on Netflix and it just
dropped on there just probably a couple
of days ago this is another Spanish film
a thriller and it's called the occupant
the Spanish version the Spanish title is
hogar which I guess means home and this
was actually a really good one I don't
think I didn't like it as much as the
platform but I liked it better than that
serial-killer e1 that Silence of the
Lambs ripoff e1 that I saw like a few
weeks ago so this one is kind of like
it's about this guy who's like an older
guy isn't like old old but he's probably
like maybe in his 50s or something and
he's an ad executive and his name is
Xavier and I guess he got laid off from
his job like a year ago and he hasn't
been able to find another one cuz I
guess he's like too old and he's not
like hip and with-it with the with the
kids and yeah whatever bills to pay that
live off his wife yeah and he's got like
this they have like this big huge house
like their their chubby little son is in
private school picked on for being fat
and get picked on for me a fat and
whatnot so um so when he gets laid off
and he doesn't get the job and
everything like that he they end up
having to move out of their beautiful
apartment in Barcelona and they have to
move to this crappy it's not crappy but
it's like a big step to this more
working-class neighborhood and he is not
happy about it so he kind of like starts
hanging on to like remnants of his old
life like he did like he tells his wife
he's gonna sell his BMW and he doesn't
want to do it it's like she has to get a
job doing retail like the fat kid has to
go to public school and it's like all
just like this big thing of shame for
him and everything he has a fire the
maid so you know sorry I can't relate
but um but yes so what he decides to do
and this starts very slowly and
insidiously he finds that he still has a
spare key to the really big nice
apartment that they were renting and he
just decides he's gonna go out and hang
around in there you know
yeah take a [ __ ] the cornflakes guys
watch a TV there and all their family
photos and at this time the movie it was
starting to get a little bit interesting
to me because I was actually bored up
until this point and then it goes on a
little bit and then and then I get bored
later but go ahead well as it goes on
Sothis starts developing this really
weird unhealthy fascination with the
family that has moved into his old house
who he perceives as being perfect and
they have like a bunch of stuff that he
doesn't have like the the dad is like a
vice president of some big company like
their daughters like really athletic
she's like a gymnast and everything
unlike like his fat son who can't even
like run to the top of a hill without
throwing up and [ __ ] like that so he
starts getting really resentful so what
he starts doing in this crazy [ __ ]
stalker creepy way is slowly and very
deliberately insinuating himself into
the life of this family yeah using these
really really creepy underhanded means
and it just gets weirder and weirder
like how he ends up like minoo what I
mean it's like it's very deliberately
paced but I found myself like really I
was just like watching this guy going -
what the [ __ ] is this guy gonna do next
this is kind of like it reminded me a
little bit of like a throwback sort of
thriller like from one from like the 90s
or something like that like a man that
rocks the cradle or something like that
like about these kind of crazy stalker
type people that remember the one with
Judi Dench
oh [ __ ] which one was that one where she
was stalking that younger girl it kind
of reminded me of that a little bit of
like that but a male version of it
the thing is though is that are you
talking about Gretta because that wasn't
Judi Dench no there was one with Judi
Dench Oh would the girl who played am
from yeah I know I know you Judi Dench's
I just couldn't remember like yeah they
were talking about yeah I think that
must have been around 2000 run that time
okay so that was a long time ago yeah
yeah but this this is reminded me of
that but it reminded me a little bit
somatically it reminded me a little bit
of parasite
as well even though this was a guy that
was that it had everything in life and
then lost it and then started resenting
that he didn't have it anymore and he
would kind of stop at nothing to get all
of it back right about once the movie
starts winding up like that I was had
already kind of violated my 1015 minute
rule it was kind of interesting you know
for a bit but it's just not my kind of
movie Jenny liked it yeah I liked it a
lot actually it was a I was kind of
expecting a horror movie and maybe it
maybe that is I to me it was just a
stalker movie yeah it's slow-paced it
wasn't uh marketed as a horror movie so
marketed as a thriller yes wasn't really
into it you know the main it yeah it was
it was a stalker type movie um there was
kind of like I don't know I just got
like so fascinated by the premise and
then like like you said it is like very
slowly paced it's very deliberately
paced
um you know I'll put it that way so I
could be going through it with this
stalker yeah that's what they they were
effective at that you don't get I and I
was really into it I mean the guy was
the guy that was in it that his
character's name was Xavier and the
actor's name is also Xavier Gutierrez he
was actually really really good he
reminded me a little bit of a much
younger Anthony Hopkins like in his
facial expressions and stuff he came
across as a little bit a triable Lecter
II yeah they're trying to take you along
the damn stalker journey so you can go
along with it an experience at the way
the stalker does that's what it seemed
like they were try and do which I think
that was effective they tried to make
him real sympathetic especially at the
beginning they did because I mean you
felt bad because he kept getting [ __ ] on
yeah and you know what I mean so so they
did kind of get you to relate but then
like as it goes on you're like oh wow
he's a crazy person so yeah there's only
been one stalker movie that [ __ ] blew
me away and I was like man this is a
badass movie and this is it was that one
with damn Robin Williams in it but he
worked at the photo what our photo one
hour photo that was a great fun that
[ __ ] there man man we should do a
retrospective on that I've got it in
years guys
see a stalker movie that's the one you
got that was a real [ __ ] you want to see
that one it was kind of like well the
the premise of that was kind of similar
to this one where it was kind of like he
perceived like this family as being like
perfect yeah and he wanted to like Zagel
himself into their life and [ __ ]
I saw one our photo man you just never
imagined that that Robin Williams first
of all can just pull off a robbery he's
a [ __ ] psycho yeah and he was [ __ ]
scaring me about I kind of felt sorry
for him at the same time yeah that's
what and it in a way that makes him
scary yeah see one our photo you want to
see a good stock a movie see one our
photo first like that would then see
this one well you know I imagine a lot
of stalker fans have already seen one
our photo I would think yeah I think I
saw that the theater actually no
thinking about it but yeah this is I
mean if you like Spanish language stuff
if you like thrillers um a couple of
things at the end because I was reading
some other reviews of it and most people
seemed it was getting like mixed reviews
and they were like well some of the
stuff at the end was not super
believable but I that didn't really
bother me I mean there was nothing that
came out of like total left-field like
he had magic powers nothing like that
it's like some of it might have been a
little improbable but it was nothing
that wasn't like completely unrealistic
it's nothing that just made me go oh no
that like you wouldn't do that or a
person wouldn't do that so in that line
if you like thrillers it's a brand new
one I think it just came on Netflix like
March
you know 25th or something listen maybe
like less than a month ago
um but yeah check it out I thought it
was a pretty damn good tonight and I got
like all involved in dude stories he
just like went wildly off the deep end
it's just some crazy [ __ ] happen later
on but yeah definitely check it out it's
on Netflix right now
you
hey y'all so now we're talking about the
third movie for the matinee show this
week but this was another one on Netflix
kind of a horror sci-fi monster movie
kind of thing this was called dark light
yeah this is a straight-up monster movie
movies I'm like I loved this when I was
a kid back in the day this would have
been just like a cheap [ __ ]
low-budget movie with a bunch of rubber
monsters in it you don't Amane and it
would have been done real poorly but
luckily today you know I mean with the
advent of [ __ ] high technology you
can have a low-budget movie come out
pretty good yeah that looks uh pretty
[ __ ] decent yeah I mean this is a
aliens ripoff kada it does yeah it does
have aspects of aliens right but it's on
earth but so what who gives a [ __ ] this
is a movie that you watch for
entertainment you're not trying to you
know I mean you're not talking about
[ __ ] you know you know hi you know
art you know if I can Citizen Kane and
[ __ ] so it's not you're talking about
here it's it's a monster movie I would
loved it I liked it I liked it as it was
it was yeah it was a pretty basic topic
yeah um you know I've noticed that it
seemed to be getting like about 60% good
reviews and likes I spoiled well I think
the thing to I think some people
complained that they didn't like that
the narrative wasn't linear like it kind
of kept like as the the beginning shows
you kind of what happens at the end and
then it come kind of kids yeah
yeah it does do that I'm trying to get
artsy fartsy but not really I mean I
didn't find it particularly hard to
follow you know what I mean but yeah
it's basically the set up of it is I
guess it's supposed to be Mississippi
because they mention that at one point
it doesn't look like Mississippi though
it looks more like Nebraska honestly
being a product of the south that is not
Mississippi no single Mississippi accent
that foliage isn't right the houses
aren't right just just that's not
Mississippi like it's wrong I thought it
was Midwest somewhere yeah doesn't mean
the grass Kirk and thank you [ __ ] yeah I
just thought that was very odd there was
just like
one line of dialogue worse they got only
about Mississippi and I was like this
doesn't have to be Mississippi and then
they got a British scientist living in
Mississippi it right near no no there
are no British science living in
Mississippi would they be there for yes
yeah he wasn't like a scientist he was
like a weird all of this paranormal
investigator like conspiracy theorist
guy he had a website where he was
talking about except in this movie it
turns out that he's like I'm not gonna
go down there and [ __ ] you find any you
know British people in Mississippi yeah
it's like they don't even visit there
why would they don't visit there no they
be scared to gather car let's drop down
and they went through Mississippi
Alabama to keep the Panhandle here in
Florida with like [ __ ] Hillary Clinton
written on the side of the car and they
got attacked at the damn gas station I
thought they had like a bunch of gay
stuff what you guys definitely yeah you
later they were like talking about cuz
they get their places in the deep south
you don't [ __ ] around yeah I can't
remember exactly what it was but they
put like some like it wasn't anything as
crass as like we love [ __ ] or anything
like that but it was kind of like it was
something that like you know rainbow
flags and chilly you thought that [ __ ]
was real funny they [ __ ] came running
out of that gas station with guns and
[ __ ] people saying they trying to make
fun of us you know man they were
insulted but yes natives got restless
there's nothing better for them to do
except sit around and chew tobacco yeah
no stop it more to put their bless
remaining - yes she's southern and she's
sucking I did that blow them down so I
know what I'm talking about yeah it's
not that bad that's not a stereotype but
yeah I can take you to where that is
going on yeah I did man I know yeah they
got it but yeah so the thing is right so
I thought that was a little strange that
that they had like kind of a throwaway
line but she didn't really have to be in
there to mention it was Mississippi when
it's clearly not business it clearly no
um it was you know the Midwest someplace
it looked like children of the corn
honestly it was like a farm like out in
the middle of a cornfield which looked
like really really cool like the
farmhouse looked really cold looked like
a real one yeah but not a
other farmhouse no it wasn't yet that's
gonna be so yes so it's basically this
woman she moves to back to her family
home with her daughter after she's
gotten divorced and they start to think
well she starts to think that there's
something in the house the little girl
doesn't see it but there's like this
elevator in there and then there's some
[ __ ] about like her like the moms mom
like the grandma that she had ended up
in an institution and like killed
herself and stuff like saying that there
was stuff in the house and no one
believed her so there's kind of this
back-and-forth between the woman and you
know seeing [ __ ] in the house seeing
like weird lights like out in the
cornfield and not knowing what they are
seeing some [ __ ] like in the house and
stuff and people not believing her
thinking that she's having a nervous
breakdown because she's had one before I
will say that it's like like I said this
isn't like a fantastic movie it's not
like but it's a perfectly serviceable
yeah good
monster movie and I have to say I kind
of liked that design of the Bott stirs
at first I was like look at it it's very
it's odd-looking it's an odd-looking
what is supposed to be an alien no but
it's obviously they ripped off the
xenomorph in a certain way kinda got
like a big one big eye for it's [ __ ]
dumb it's kind of like a xenomorph kinda
had a clear spot on its dome yeah but
this one has a [ __ ] headlights like a
big headlight like them it's like I
assumed that was how they communicate
and also how they feed it's it's an
original design if you kinda and it
looked like practical effects now I I
think that the blinking was CGI but it
looked like the suit was real kind of
remind me what you would get if a damn
xenomorph had a baby with a [ __ ] with
a [ __ ] Sleestak it was it was
distinctly stuck like a Sleestak from
[ __ ] lanolin except with one big
giant eye on stuff yeah and they came
from underneath the ground yeah they
weren't aliens I don't know I think it
was like another type of humanoid yes
they evolved here on planet earth yeah
yeah we kind of spoiled it but it
doesn't [ __ ] matter because back when
I was a kid this this [ __ ] would have
been corneas [ __ ] I still would have
loved it been funny probably yeah but it
would've been corneas
and elect it I mean I was like I said
it's a very simple monster movie it's
not super complicated it's not trying to
do anything fancy it is a monster movie
yeah and you know what I mean it was
trendy it's short it's only an hour and
a half you know there's a lot of like
people creeping around in the house and
like shadows and [ __ ] like behind there
and it's like you know you're not you're
not entirely sure what it is because it
takes a while for them to like show the
monster but they do show it this is
exact kind of movie when I was a little
kid my dad says come on let's go see a
mouse or movie see the monster oh [ __ ]
this one was satisfied I probably was
very scared this is yeah this monster
probably would've scared me shitless one
yeah just because it's a lot is so
weird-looking
oh yeah it's good I used to love to get
scared yeah me too
buy the [ __ ] monster movies I did too
I still do actually yeah I felt [ __ ]
brave and manly
did you get scared yeah yeah I could
tell you guys scared you know he's still
scared no no thinking about it thinking
about in the back of my head you know
and then later on when you're really
little you look up in the middle of the
night looking for that monster is it
part of growing up man it is I still
love [ __ ] monster movies anyway but
yeah so this is a perfectly good head
Lee I really liked actually like the end
parts where the monster was like
attacking people and doing its thing
that it did to them I thought that
looked actually pretty cool it reminded
me a little bit of the original movie
The Dark Crystal where I think it was
wasn't it the Skeksis that would like
suck out the life force from the little
pod legs or whatever I guess it was no
like their faces would go and like all
the way yeah another good thing about
the movie said it was all practical
effects in it so it was kind of had a
throwback element to it and I like the
practical effects is kind of like kind
of cross between alien and species not
leaving species yeah there's like things
that the one with the woman trying to
like meet with yeah no but I was
thinking about there was like somebody
laying there in a damn vat yeah yeah
that's right that was cool laying in fat
so you see it yeah there was like five
and everything
you know yeah there was like some really
cool visuals yeah reminded me a little
bit of signs also yeah yeah exactly
that's what the cornfield we're feeling
the invisible aliens of [ __ ] yeah even
though these weren't technically aliens
but I mean they just roll with it yeah
roll with it you drink when you're
watching it you laugh at it you know
what I mean laughs with it and go yeah
all right
it's just that that's the beauty of a
monster movie and there's something
about the lower-budget monster movies
for some reason it I don't know if it's
that they have the freedom to do
whatever the [ __ ] they want to do so
they just show you what they want didn't
have to go through a committee and
there's something a little more I don't
know it's gonna be hit and miss you
don't ya know it's gonna be hit and miss
it's not gonna be highly polished I like
that better
yeah I do for a monster movie in this
genre I'd rather have that yeah I would
as well I think that and I think a lot
of horror fans that are into that kind
of movies like that I think that's why a
lot of them like kind of the older ones
are you know ones that don't also ones
that don't take themselves entirely too
so you know what this reminded me of too
in a certain way extra member that all
want extra yeah it was a little bit like
that what is weird I mean extra is
pretty [ __ ] weird
we don't do a retrospective on that I
don't think a lot of people have seen it
loosen ations and weird stuff like that
you know yeah I said yeah stuff like
that trying not to say and stuff like
that because you say that I know same
stuff like that now I'm gonna buy got it
know I get to wacky you've infected me
with it it's like a virus well yeah well
the good thing about Extro is that you
get to see a full-grown man come out of
a woman's vagina yeah you know yeah
everything's cool I like special yeah I
liked that movie it's weirdest [ __ ] it's
like it has the weirdest [ __ ] premise
yeah first time I saw it I was probably
15 or 16 I was in Brazil man oh so it's
more like what just got done smoking
weed I was high I wasn't really sure if
I got what I got that's what I mean I
don't know if I'd wanted it I don't know
if I'd want to watch that higher you
might not recover from that but yeah a
couple things I wanted to mention this
is um written directed by a guy named
Padraig Reynolds that's a very Celtic
name isn't it he's done a couple other
movies but I haven't seen either one of
them
the maid woman that's in this the
actress I thought she looked a little
bit familiar Jessica Matson her name is
she was in the new Rambo movie ok and
she was in Leatherface - Irish or
someone I'm not really sure actually um
I I just assumed that because the
director's name sounded so Hybris I
thought there was a bunch of stuff in
there and the credits this sounded
foreign - oh maybe there was but I don't
know I don't know where I ain't getting
that confused with the variant of Aryan
which actually was that dia they had a
lot of Irish in like Scandinavian stuff
yeah that was a world of funding anyway
I'm not really sure where they shot it
though I think they shot it that was a
good one but this one I mean yeah I mean
I have to say Bavarian was easily
hands-down my favorite of the week I
mean you know the the other two that we
saw were good but it's like I think the
very very messy yeah yeah if you can
only see one woke up the next warrants
to wondering about that movie yeah I'm
like still thinking about it yeah I'm
like watching it you know it's a good
movie when you immediately go to youtube
and watch like all these other videos
about it like other people talking about
it but yeah so like I said if you got
Netflix used in the mood for kind of
creepy short monster movie you can
certainly do worse than watching darkly
cuz it's pretty funny yeah I thought
with a cool monster you know okay one
slow part in it yeah yeah and it didn't
last that long yeah like I said to my
dad it's only an hour and a half you
don't really have to know anything or
pay attention to it you can just kind of
yeah it basically just they're in this
farmhouse and monsters are gonna cash it
yeah that's pretty much all you need to
know but yeah so check it out
[Music]